The joe rogan experience.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
It's new.
It's something,
you know,
it's some real,
in this world of package to bullshit,
you know,
over and over again.
Some of these fucking bands that they're just keep pushing.
It's like,
what is this fucking bullshit on the highway to fuck?
Speaking of bands,
oh by the way,
we are sponsored by the fleshlight.
Um,
so anyway,
we're sponsored by them.
And what we were talking about before we got into that was this thing on the
highway today in Los Angeles there was a band and was the band called perial
stars imperial stars.
Now I didn't know about this.
I lucky I missed this.
I didn't leave the house today,
but um,
when it happened apparently was these guys got on the highway and they turned
their,
their stopped their truck and turned it sideways so that the create a traffic
jam.
And then they started saying,
yeah,
the biggest piece of attention whoring may be anyone's ever done stood on the
truck playing music by the way.
Like they had like full now these dumb motherfuckers probably thought that this
was like,
this is like the opening scene in our movie,
man.
This is it.
It's like they were so wild.
Like this is how they got discovered.
They got on top of the truck and they stopped traffic and the fucking music was
so good.
People who didn't care man get it.
Yeah.
And the crazy thing is,
is they actually,
I listened to the song,
I don't know if you've heard it.
I have not heard it.
If I want to hate them,
I know.
If it was really good I would have been like,
damn,
there's no way it could be really good cause it's w it was really good.
They wouldn't be willing to do this.
It just makes you have to be a Douche bag.
You have to be a Douche bag to want to stop traffic and get on the news and do
all this at other people's expense.
Right.
Because you want to be known for your fucking music.
Fuck you.
Especially in this city where that fucking row.
What about people who are on the way to the hospital?
What about people were on the way to serious emergencies?
What about people that lost their job because of you?
That was the one day that were late again over the mark are,
you know,
maybe if it had a fucking thing,
if you're late again this month you're fired and they were fired because you
fuck you dude.
Even if the song is all about traffic on the one on one,
that's the bad thing.
That's the song is all about and what sucks is that every news place it's going
to talk about this and you know,
there's so many dumb asses out there that's going to like fall for this whole
trick and they're going to become their,
their Twitter account went up today.
I'm assuming a bit that I maybe,
I'm sure they did.
I'd probably fall.
Listen,
I would have hope for the,
they'll say something really stupid,
but I mean that we just have to discourage that kind of shit.
You can't do that,
man.
You can't.
You know,
it's one thing if you want to do something for publicity and it doesn't fuck
with everybody else's life,
but when you want to do something like that in La and you want to stop traffic,
just so that you get a tension essentially,
like this is how we're going to make it,
man,
this is brilliant publicity style.
Like you guys are idiots.
That's an idiot move,
man.
It sucks.
And look,
you know,
maybe a bounce back from it and you maybe you fucked up and maybe you guys were
all high on coke and it seems like an awesome idea.
I'm not saying you shitty human beings.
You fucked though.
You want to hear this song
is fucking song.
Right?
Wow.
Okay.
All right.
Now actually I,
hold on,
I forgot.
I can't do that on this computer.
Remember it gets right.
I can't get him to do it on the IPAD.
Yeah.
Hold on a second.
So,
uh,
talk about some joy.
Listen man,
I totally understand the appeal for all of these reality shows where all these
people become famous for no reason.
And then people go,
fuck man,
it's all just about getting eyes on you and then once you get eyes on you,
you can be a business and you can even use that for good.
You can go on Oprah Style and fucking save the world with all the money.
You know?
Maybe Kim Kardashians is going to do that,
so maybe all this will become a good thing.
But the,
because of that,
people are trying to find ways to get attention outside of the normal shit
outside of being recognized for something recognized for what you do.
You know this fucking Dee aunt word is perfect.
However you say it.
Diane would die at Word Diet Ward.
That rap band.
We were playing it.
We don't,
we haven't,
there's no publicity stunts.
There's nothing.
They didn't fucking start a fire in a mall.
All they did was make bad ass music and it got on youtube and everybody's like,
dude,
this is the shit.
Check this out.
This is fucking cool.
It's real smart.
They did it to the whole clip is like two minutes long.
Is this the song dude in?
It's really poor green screen effects.
Okay.
So it's a,
this is really low.
Can we turn it off?
[inaudible]
stuck in
traffic.
So it sounds,
it sounds like to me it's like a fake video used inside a movie.
You know,
like tropic thunder,
look at this new video that's on.
It's fun.
That's what it sounds like to me.
Perfect way of describing it,
dude.
That is the perfect way to describe fake videos.
They're playing musicians,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
They do look like you even had a wig on.
Two got fabulous hair.
Don't hate,
I think,
um,
yeah,
they're,
they sounded like they're playing musicians.
I just hope there's no trying to get famous it bad.
I mean it was,
I couldn't say it was terrible.
I just hope there's another like copy catters you know,
like,
oh Mike Acoustic people,
you know,
putting their bikes in the middle of a highway.
You got to talk people,
we hit that guy might have started something and you know,
the economy is bad,
but what the fuck people,
yeah.
You know,
damn,
what if that does happen?
What do people started doing that all the time now?
I think they're going to make a,
make an example out of these guys,
they're probably going to charge them a lot of money.
Yeah.
What if it's nothing?
What if it's like,
no,
it's gotta be something that's got to be something big because they blocked
traffic.
That's like a felony.
I think what they did for publicity's,
I think it's fairly serious,
right?
I think,
um,
I think they could go to jail.
It's actually possible they go to jail for something like that.
Like unlawful restraint.
You're an offer restraint.
Yeah.
You can put like a kidnapping charge on danger to you put human beings danger to
your clothes off the highways and make,
make it tough for people to get around ambulances.
You know,
someone's dad could have died because you know,
there's a heart attack and they rushed him to the hospital and they can't get
there in time because you fucking decided to sing in the road.
You can't fuck you.
You know,
that's just dumb.
And everybody,
you know,
everybody should react the same way to them.
Even if you like him.
He's like,
oh,
that was a dumb move,
man.
There's just something so not cool.
Something should start from this like it's a new tradition.
Every time you see these guys in public,
you have to throw a tomato at them.
They should charge them for everybody that was late.
Think about all the people that were late,
thousands and thousands of people that were late there.
Their employers have to pay the person for the time that they weren't even at
work because they were stuck in a traffic jam because these assholes,
they should all like,
they should like,
they could stack all that up.
They should like find out,
okay,
what do you get?
You get $50 an hour.
All right,
this guy gets 20 bucks an hour and this guy,
okay,
45 minutes and we'll calculate it up and you know,
and Oh,
you owe $1 million.
You Fuck?
Yeah.
This guy was auditioning for iron man for he could've made this much money.
Yeah,
you crazy.
Yeah.
You could get crazy.
Like I had a fishing in a dream.
I knew it was going to happen for me.
Everything in my vision was absolutely perfect and true,
except you decided to sing on the fucking freeway.
What would have been smarter if they hired these guys at these guys were
homeless guys and they were,
they made like this fake video up just to make it look like they were the ones
singing.
But the real band hired these people to get in trouble,
to go to jail so they wouldn't get in trouble I think.
And the problem with a band like that,
is it anybody that would come up with a stunt like that,
it's not going to be good.
Right?
You're just not going to be good.
Right.
Because obviously aren't famous yet.
What's not?
And even not the,
you're not famous yet.
Obviously there's a lot of good bands that aren't famous.
It's about being famous in the music business is a fucking weird thing.
It doesn't really make sense.
It's not that easy.
It's tricky,
you know,
it's like,
but with the Internet,
like look at this word thing,
you can get famous.
You just have to put something together.
And their shit was cheap.
I mean it wasn't,
there was nothing.
No.
For the high tech,
nothing to it from South Africa.
We know about him.
Oh Man.
I mean he did.
They did it right.
You know,
it's,
but it's,
it's tricky like to try to like get record sales and shit and get in the door
and get played on the radio and everything.
It's like man,
it's a fucking funky business.
And it got gutted because of the MP3S online.
Like the music business is a state of shambles.
You know,
it's interesting with something like this,
Dee aunt word comes in and shakes things up,
but it's annoying when you see the other manifestations of it,
like these assholes with their fucking bus on the highway.
It's just,
it's just sad that someone would decide to do that.
That you would be so fucking selfish and stupid.
You would want to block off a main route just so that you could,
you know,
make it man,
the kid fucking make it.
Wow.
I mean,
what are the odds those guys aren't annoying as fuck.
Here's a,
here's a quote.
The band describes themselves as rock stars living on the edge.
They're known for getting crazy and hanging out with their friends.
That's a real quote.
Shut the fuck up.
I swear to God.
Fucking La times.com.
I'm reading it right now.
What the fuck up the band?
The band.
This is a subtle colony.
Wait a minute.
I'm starting to like them.
I'm starting to become a thing.
I think I just became a thing.
No,
wait,
is it 180 degree turn around?
This is a subtle comedy.
My bad internet.
This is a subtle comedy,
Dude.
No,
I think we're missing out.
We're missing.
I'm on La time.
Dot.
Where's this funny quotes about three sentences and members arrested after
blocking one-on-one freeway.
Okay.
That la times blogs and I want you to read it now,
but I want you to read it.
How they wrote it too.
Oh my God.
Where's,
where's yours?
Is it the same way?
I emailed it.
Same way you mount it to your here.
You want to look at it right here?
Yeah.
Okay.
The band describes itself,
says rock stars.
Now.
This is an all caps with an exclamation point.
Oh,
living on the edge.
They're known for getting crazy and hanging out with their friends.
Okay.
It says they debuted in 2010 with a hardcore hip hop album,
but wait a minute.
Are they rock stars or are they hardcore hip hop artists?
They can do anything.
That is crazy.
Is that a new thing that's going on now?
Like hip hop and rock?
It's just this all together.
It's just a setting and garage band nowadays so they can do anything they
wanted.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
The band describes itself.
I'll say this again.
For those of you who haven't crashed your fucking cars in furious white knuckled
anger at these cunts.
The Ben described itself as rock stars live in the on the edge.
They're known for getting crazy and hanging out with their friends.
That's a real quality.
He's seen the truck to that that was pulled over that was like,
oh,
it looks like Wayne's world
fucking picture of them.
It looks like something from Wayne's world.
It looks vague.
It doesn't even look real.
I hope this is not a movie.
It might be.
They might be brilliant.
It seems like it is.
Like I said,
like I said,
it seemed like a fake band inside of a movie.
What full thing is a fake hand?
I bet it is.
There just is.
No.
Well,
if they are,
come on man,
then they're really fucked because if they make a movie and they closed the
highway down for a movie like that.
Yeah.
No,
I don't believe that because first of all,
you would have cameras everywhere.
You'd have real cameras.
He wouldn't have a fucking little youtube cameras or they're going to do a stunt
like this.
They're going to have to have like real permits.
But look,
how could that photo is?
It's crazy.
Photos.
Perfect.
They turn the car sideways,
turned sideways.
It's perfect lighting.
It's perfect.
It even looks like it kind of caught Tam.
And if this is a movie,
I want to be really mad.
I'm already mad.
This devil mad.
Um,
I,
I'm hoping that these guys were like Andy Kaufman.
They'll just,
he's brilliant artists.
You know,
you're not like that.
The quote is so bad.
This band describes itself as rock stars.
This is all in caps,
living on the edge.
They're known for getting crazy and hanging out with their friends.
Right?
That's what they're known for is this guy.
My neighborhood,
this guy,
he's fucking crazy.
He hangs out with his friends.
That's how you say it.
Like you lived in Glendale though.
If they totally changed the whole sentence,
you'll member walks.
Doves were living on the edge.
You know,
they're getting,
we'd like to get crazy and hanging with the blue or Flynn's not an Armenian guy.
You're doing,
what is that?
I sense that a Swedish Swedish.
Wow.
Um,
I listen,
I think that these guys,
uh,
if,
if this is a scam and if this is just a,
a hustle,
then I dunno,
I'm on the fence.
I'm on the fence now.
It's not like if they decided to make a bad band on purpose,
I might think this is pretty fucking,
if the song was good.
That's what I was saying.
Remember when we went to see that band steel panther?
That was good music.
Fucking awesome music if you haven't seen those guys.
Steel Panther or this,
they do this like eighties um,
thing where they play like all the,
like the best eighties rock and they,
the dude does the most insane Ozzy Osborne impression man.
And it's all like hair,
metal stuff.
It's all like,
you know,
like,
and,
and it's good man.
It's good music but it's like this like hilarious good music parody on.
But you love it because you know they're a fake band,
right?
You know,
but they're good.
These guys,
what if they are fake Ben too?
But they,
but they didn't do the good part of the music so it doesn't go together.
It doesn't work.
It has to actually cause cause cause I,
if I liked these guys and I respect,
I'm actually have to get into their music and I'm not,
what am I going to hang out with these guys and become friends with them,
whatever.
It's just this brilliant performance piece which just make the worst,
most cliche,
bland,
dumb wrap.
And we'll do it with like a lot of confidence and let's see if we could sell it.
What if they just want to make friends?
Maybe this is just a friend thing.
Like they,
they,
you won't like their music,
but they just want be your friend while they do hang out with their friends,
they're known for that.
They're known for getting crazy and hanging out with her friends.
Right.
It's a big friend thing.
How many people right now are going to change their Avatar,
their fucking signature under their Avatar on the road board now too.
He's known for getting crazy and hanging out with his friends.
You fucking dummy.
You shut up dummy.
It makes God dammit everybody's doe.
Yeah.
And they,
because of this band Joey did wasn't here today.
Yeah.
This fucking band.
The,
these cut holes,
when they decided to do that,
Joey Diaz is a,
he was filming something today and it wasn't gonna be able to make it over and
Tom with traffic.
So we flew solo because he,
you,
you twats
okay.